paie Shore announced he's playing
Richard Simmons did you see that yes the
movie comes off the release of a short
film The Court Jester by a sketch comedy
group The Lewis Brothers who cast Paulie
as Richard the short film premiered at
Sundance over the weekend Paulie feels
there's no reason why he can't pull off
an Oscar worthy performance listen to
this you know we put this out there at
Sundance we get some press and it goes
out on the internet ethra goes back out
there and all you beautiful people share
it weirder things have happened okay
Brandon Frasier and kilon Quan got
Oscars this last year there's no [__]
reason why paully Shore can't [__]
immerse himself into the role of Richard
Simmons who America [__] needs
and be gets a [__]
nomination sometimes people just need
opportunities that's what life's about
opportunities and if I get the
opportunity to Star a Richard Simmons
biopic I will deliver because I take
things very seriously I will immerse
myself in the body Soul and Spirit of
Richard Simmons well Brendan Frasier was
an enino man and he got an osar and
that's what I think he's referring to
others of his
co-stars have done very well the two
dudes from Ino man have gotten Oscars
why can't Paulie get one meanwhile as
you said Robin Richard Simmons came out
of hiding to denounce the movie on his
Facebook page he says uh hi everybody
you may have heard they may be doing a
movie about me with Paulie sh I have
never given my permission for this movie
so I don't believe everything you read I
no longer have a manager and I no longer
have a publicist I just try to live a
quiet life and be peaceful in other
words hey please [__] off and don't do
this thank you for all your love and
support Richard I didn't see expect
Richard at the premiere I didn't see
this 10-minute Paulie movie but I do
have a clip from it what's my first
rule like
yourself
your weight doesn't matter if you like
yourself you're going to be
fine but I've been where you are right
now and where I'm right now is I just
love myself every part of myself and I
think I can show you how to get
here please welcome
Richard Paulie says he wants the movie
to be more dramatic than funny but
well you GNA be Richard Simmons I'm
going to tell you a story there is no
such thing as Richard Simmons being like
lowkey off camera because I had Richard
to my house for a dinner back in the I
want to say the 80s would have been the
90s I don't know and uh let me tell you
something Richard Richard was on well I
used to go to shows with him and he
would be s singing to people in the
aisles before
before I know Paulie wants a
serious Richard but I never saw any
evidence of that guy but Richard um
Richard was always over the top so he
walks into my house he he picked up the
housekeeper and squeezed her really high
and she was flipped out then he grabbed
me so hard my ribs hurt like I I was
like Richard let would go of me and then
I made some cucumber or derves that I
had actually prepared myself and he I
served him one and he took it and threw
it in the pool and then started tossing
cucumbers into the pool oh my goodness
that's when I went into full recluse
life
because it it was a disaster Richard
forced you back inside he forced me back
inside
but no he's a great guy I thought he was
a real caring human being and I think
that's why he eventually just
disappeared
because he really got affected by the
people he helped and I think it became
too much of a burden but I'm going to
tell him I hope Richard's listening to
this or someone could get him a tape of
the show because I'm going to tell him
what he should do Richard Simmons should
make a movie where he plays Paulie Shaw
and see if paully likes it what do you
think of
that